ja wer ist der echte michael wendler
eigentlich soviel ist sicher
der comedian oder bönstrup wie wir im
beitrag gesehen haben ist das nicht er
hat einen fake account eingerichtet auf
denen tausende reingefallen ist warum
und wie er das gemacht hat das wird er
uns jetzt live erklären ich bin zum ist
mir jetzt zugeschaltet wenn sie gleich
die frage warum und wie haben sie das
gemacht
ich bin ich das mach ich bin nicht herr
bönstrup sondern ich bin sein kollege
und freund tobias huch ich glaube ich
das ist glaube ich ein bisschen schief
gegangen also und ich haben das
gemeinsam gemacht und zwar um
aufzuzeigen wie schnell fake news
verbreitet werden können wie schnell
menschen auf irgendetwas einfallen was
im internet steht das ist ja die basis
auf der die meisten
verschwörungstheorien wachsen und
gedeihen
man braucht sich nur attila hildmann
ansehen der ja auch jeden mist verlinkt
den er im internet findet das ist so
absurd aber menschen glauben auf einmal
nur weil es auch irgend einer
internetseite steht oder weil es ein
youtube video gibt oder irgendetwas
anderes
ja sowieso erstmal entschuldigung von
unserer seite wir reden mit dem es
echten tobias huch und nicht mit oder
bönstrup so soll hier mal klar sagen
nicht dass auch da noch zu verwirrung
kommt sagen sie uns einmal vielleicht
ist es denn so einen fake account
überhaupt einzurichten ist ja so
täuschend echt aus dass ebensoviele
drauf reingefallen sind ja michael
wendler hat uns natürlich auch sehr sehr
einfach gemacht also er hat ja in seinem
video gesagt michael wendler offiziell
und sein account heißt leicht anders und
so konnten wir natürlich dann auch auf
telekom michael wendler offiziell
anmelden haben dann eben noch so ein
icon sind so ein schlecht geführtes
grünes grünen haken danebengesetzt viele
kennen den blauen haken von facebook
oder von twitter und dann sind die
massen rein geströmt aber auch große
seiten wie die festivalleitung sind
direkt drauf reingefallen und da sieht
man ja auch wie gerade diese influenza
oder oder multiplikatoren dieser
verschwörungstheorien wie einfach die zu
täuschen sind und auf welche ist ihre
einfallen wie ist eine telekom gruppe
die man hätte mit ein bisschen recherche
durchaus als fähig hätte erkennen können
haben sie denn in der zwischenzeit auch
von michael wendler persönlich was
gehört
nein es ist ja leicht zeitversetzt er
postet ja zu urzeiten die er den usa
entsprechen ich sehe was er so schreibt
und wir haben uns jetzt dazu entschieden
dass wir künftig auf alle seine postings
die er bei seiner richtigen
verschwörungstheorie gruppe bringt ein
faktencheck anschließen da werden wir
dann richtige inhalte verlinken unter
anderem inhalte die auch große seiten
wie volksverhetzer oder korrektiv
anbieten da sind ja hochseriöse fakten
checker die eher wissenschaftlich
arbeiten und nicht irgendwelchen mist
aus irgendwelchen blogs
vielleicht noch ein wort an die
enttäuschten fans die jetzt diesem
account gefolgt sind was war ihre
message warum haben sie das gemacht was
wollten sie damit zeigen
also die messe schon war ganz war ganz
klar leute lasst euch nicht täuschen von
dem was im internet ist ihr fall so
schnell auf irgendwelchen quatsch rein
prüft alles doppelt und dreifach geht
auf seriöse quellen glaubt einfach nicht
was euch irgendein dahergelaufener promi
erzählt ob er jetzt attila hildmann
heißt oder michael wendler
das sind am ende alle gestalten die
jeden mist und am ende hass und hetze
verbreiten
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren